um one of the one of the squadrons had
just returned from northern ireland
and they had like a welcome back party
in the camp camp bar
there is a course called um assault
engineers where infantry can come do
engineering courses
and there was an infantry unit called
the fusiliers who were on camp doing
that but they'd
they're troublemakers basically they're
banned from downtown because they're
always causing trouble so they were on
camp
and this evening that they had the big
uh the family get together they were in
the bar as well
and me and my friend could see they're
being quite rude to some of the
calling pads wives you know the lad's
wives you know uh
so me and my friend you know decided to
open up on a couple of them so we ended
up you know
putting down free guys my my my sergeant
major came in is that right you boys go
to bed you know it's brushed under the
carpet
i was then rudely awoken by a military
policeman two hours later
said you're under arrest and um
so before i went over to five nine
commando i there was possibility
that i could be getting court-martialed
for this fight
so i went over anyway i did the first
week of the beat up
and then the course staff sergeant pulls
me and he said you you've got to fly to
germany
they're doing an id parade i was like
okay so id parade is some kind of
investigation
investigation with the police yeah they
want to line you up with other
other other guys and are you are you
like totally distraught at this point
um i'm not totally distraught you do
worry about your career how this can
can affect your your career so i i flew
over and
me at the time i still hadn't grown into
my ears so i just stood out like
you know a sore thumb and and they all
knew me as the pti so
straight away they just bee-lined yeah
that's the guy
my friend who did it with me however his
his brother was in the squadron as well
so he never got picked out so i was like
okay great
um so i flew back to finish the beat up
you know they said yeah you're fit
enough you're ready
so went on and did the did the commander
course and
um when we finished the command of
course ten weeks later we go back to
five nine commando
and the oc is like that he said right
guys you guys are going across the water
and the squadron were in northern
ireland so i thought perfect we're off
to northern ireland he said not you stop
he said you're going across the other
water you're going back to germany i
said we need to get this
get this cleared so i went back to
germany and um
basically they said look you can go
court-martial and it probably would get
thrown out but that's gonna
be another 12 months to 18 months you
know i've just passed the command of
course i wanted to go
be with the commandos so i just pleaded
guilty
um i got charged and so i spent 56 days
in the military correction
training center which is colchester
prison known as the glass house
and but the the commanding officer
actually because everyone knew
it was me and the other guy you know
they and they knew these guys were
troublemakers
they're like yeah you just unfortunately
got caught out so the commanding officer
was an airborne guy airborne engineers
this is the commanding officer at
colchester
no no this is this is the german yeah no
this is in germany
okay you know so i have to leave that
unit first and so the rsm matches me and
the rsm was one of
a football player with me and uh and
he's like outright you know
sapper stott um i was gonna give you 60
days
but because you've done the all-arms
commander course i've taken four days
off
any questions i said yes if i'd gone
airborne would have got more days off
and he sort of giggled and he said like
you know it's time for you to go
so so yeah i spent 56 days in
her majesty's corrective training center
yeah i was looking i didn't know what
colchester was but it's basically
it's the same term echo charles when you
hear somebody say
leavenworth what do you think of prison
yeah military prison
that's kind of the way culture is i
think it's the last military prison
really in england there's so there's not
it's everybody knows it the glass house
it's the glass it's the equivalent of
leavenworth yeah and and everyone has
you know you hear horror stories coming
out of the glass house and what and what
it actually
is is because when you you have an
escort that drops you off
and the instructors are there to meet
you and it's like it is like a scenario
full metal jacket they are screaming and
shouting at you but as soon as they've
gone
they just treat you like adults you know
i mean it's um they take away all those
sort of
those creature comforts you know you
don't you're not allowed to phone anyone
it's um two pt sessions a day
it's room inspections all the time i
actually really enjoyed colchester
um i said if if i got paid full
full wages i would i would have really
enjoyed it and it got to a stage
actually where guys were going into
colchester
and coming out better soldiers a lot
better soldiers and they were actually
getting promoted when they got back to
their units and they had to stop that
they said no it's
you know you're there for the wrong you
know for bad bad reasons you can't be
seen to be
be promoted so i did i did my time there
and um went back to five nine